please join me in welcoming Kim
wenson thanks very
much well thank you very much for that
introduction and let me start by saying
thank you to Bob and doy King for what I
think is a remarkable initiative and one
that is certainly much needed and I
think all of us are very grateful to you
both for taking the lead in doing this
I'm sure Stanford is very lucky to have
you and um and from what I've seen in
the morning discussions it's off to a
very good
start uh I have I think 20 minutes to
cover the entire field of
development um which will lead a little
time uh for questions but let let me
start by saying that U the purpose of
the Institute I think is to deal with
three particular subjects if I
understand correctly the institutional
the managerial and the
technological and I think it is very
good indeed that uh we should try and
bring this whole field down to three
specific areas in which there can be
particular attention given to research
and development and teaching which we
talked about this
morning I don't have any great knowledge
of the plans of the professorial group
other than what I learned this morning
and in the next day and a half I think
they're going to be telling you what it
is they're interested in doing so don't
let me preempt their
pitch what I'd like to do in starting
this off is to really draw attention to
something that I learned very early in
my activities in the development field
and then carried over to uh my work at
the World Bank uh for that
decade and it basically is that you
cannot think of
any of these initiative institutional
managerial technological or indeed any
particular initiative in development
unless you have a framework in which
you're
operating if the framework isn't there
then by doing uh projects you will find
very quickly that they've been for not I
remember first when I was down in Ghana
on one of my early trips I went to see
uh a school the school had been built
two years
before and all that was left of it was a
shell the pipes had been taken out the
windows had been taken out the lights
had been taken out and I had a picture
of what it was previously in that two
years and it got me thinking you know
this is really terrible the gun ANS
don't know how to how to uh deal with
things even when they get them until I
realized that it was not really the gun
an's fault or the community fault
nothing had been put into the systemic
approach to having a
school they didn't have separate toilets
for the boys and girls they didn't have
a methodology of getting the kids to
school they did not
have uh an appropriate way in which they
could close the school off at night and
guard it and they did not have adequate
textbooks the girls could not go to
school because they couldn't get there
and in any event they were needed at
home for household work and therefore
their parents wouldn't let them
go uh and so on and so on until we
realize that if you're going to build a
school You' better keep in mind how you
going to run it how you going to get the
kids there how you going to fix the
parents to make sure that they they're
in support which by the way in the end
you generally solve by paying them a few
dollars if they get the kids to school
that in order to get the kids to school
and have them healthy you've got to take
them for health
tests if you're going to have them
effective in the school you want to try
and stimulate them in the first five
years of life which is well known for as
a development issue and if you don't do
that you'll get kids going to school
that are already somewhat damaged by the
time that they get there and I could go
on and extend to you the the range of
both the prior requirements and also the
objectives of going to that school but
the point is that when you start
thinking about doing an individual
project you have to look at it within
its overall context you cannot just say
I'll put down a school because if that's
all you're doing you're almost certain
that it'll be stabl and it'll be torn
apart within two
years the other thing is that in the
development field and in many countries
I saw this you would find that if there
was one school built you might have five
schools built because all of the
different agencies of different
governments and private
organizations decide that they need to
build a school and so instead of having
no school you'll have five schools and
one will be a religious school one will
be a local school one will be a school
put up by an international agency one
will be a national supported School and
that leads you to the next thing that
development without some planning and
without some integration of effort is a
tremendously wasteful thing and can be
very wasteful and one of the things that
uh we discovered in the work that I was
doing is that when people have money to
build a school they don't want anybody
else interfering particularly someone
that has nothing to do with
it then the third thing that happens uh
typically when when money is provided
for these projects and I use the school
simply as an
example is that the wastage that occurs
in terms of individual projects becomes
profound I concluded that in many of the
countries in which I was operating with
the which we were operating at the
bank that the losses on projects could
be as much as 80% in terms of the money
that got to the
project the losses being as a result of
a multiplicity of
effort straight
stealing uh which was probably the major
cause the whole issue of
corruption bad
planning
and not only stealing by the promoters
but by the government and by all the
people that are associated with
it and so the prime issue which we
needed to deal with in so many of the
projects in which we were operating was
to make sure that you had transparency
and you could actually make effective
the projects that you were trying to
bring
about and that's true not just a
physical project it's also true of the
initiatives which our hosts are talking
about how do you make sure that the
money that you're going to put into
institutional managerial or
technological change will in fact get
there and who is monitoring it so the
issue of management which is so
adequately deal with in this institution
the issue of management becomes
absolutely Central to the effectiveness
that you can have in the development
process and it is one of the principal
reasons that I think it's so great that
this school should be situated here
because it's not just business
management that we're talking about
we're talking about management of
projects in the development
field I jotted
down uh the four things that the Board
of Governors of the World Bank decided
in
[Music]
1998 were the principles that you needed
to have in these
projects the first one was develop
strategies that should be
comprehensive that covers the point that
I just made a school alone is not
comprehensive if you want to do an
education program it has to have all
those other things associated with it
and we developed a thing called the
comprehensive development framework
which dealt with the social the
structural
considerations such as expanding not
just in individual projects but
expanding the totality of how you
approach development and it starts with
Education Health Care it gets on with
infrastructure it gets on with roads
that you need to get there with training
of the Next
Generation I'm only hinting it now
because I've only got 20 minutes but the
truth of the matter is that you have to
create around each of these projects
an environment in which you're not going
to lose something with the water flowing
through that hole you have to have a a
systemic
approach the second thing is that you
shouldn't impose it either from Stamford
or from Harvard or from Washington or
from the
outside the thing that you learn when
you get into the field and I went to
over 140 countries is that the countries
that
El know their problems and want to be
part of the
solution the issue is listen to what the
people in the countries are doing don't
have your meetings in Washington or in
Geneva have your meetings in the
countries themselves because they're the
place that really has the responsibility
of delivery they're the place that needs
it and they will always know more than
you do about the country and their
culture
and that's why I think even in what this
institution uh is talking about the seed
institution you're talking and you
mentioned it this morning of the very
great need to have local offices in many
of these places so that you can in fact
draw on the experience of the
locality and you would have thought that
that was something that everybody was
doing but in fact it's not what
everybody was doing the typical uh
rationale in international organizations
the official ones was that if you wanted
to get promoted you had to stay in
Washington or Geneva or wherever the
head office was and so you made these
trips but actually living there was not
something that you really wanted to do
the alternative was or the other side of
the story was that in the
non-governmental
organizations most of them would go out
into the field and you have five eight
10 organizations from NOS all offering
to do the same thing
in the local community and not talking
to each other so you'd have five Land
Rovers and you'd have five officers and
you'd have five teams that were there
ready to do what was ever was to be done
and that was part of the cause of the
loss of the funds that were going into
development and so what was essential
was to try and bring them together so
that you could have a more rational
approach if you could find a leader that
would
acceptable and over the recent years I
think that's happened more and more with
the ability of Civil Society to get
together and to deal with it so in the
countries you had governments you have
donors have Civil Society you have
Academia they have the private sector
all stakeholders in trying to get
something done and if you don't listen
to what the others are doing you have
replication you have confusion and
certainly you have a lot of waste so the
issue of management which the school can
deal with is a critical issue and by the
way provides a great opportunity for
careers not only for the three
professors that have already been named
but I hope for a lot of people that will
come through the
school and then there's the issue of
um measuring performance how do you
measure performance how do you get
measurable
results do you measure it just on the
amount of money that's being spent and
how quickly spend it which by the way
until recent years was mainly the way
that development expenditures were
measured or do you look at the
effectiveness of what's been happening
and try and see whether you have are
approaching or nearly approaching the
sort of results that you had hoped to
do and why I'm saying all this to you is
that you talk about
development as being a wonderful
socially responsible thing which indeed
it is
addressing the question of the billion
under a dollar and a quarter a day and
by the way the three and a half billion
under $2.50 a day which is your next
Target after you've done the
billion uh so we have plenty of work to
do you have this issue of how is it that
you can in a local
community design a program which is
effective
locally which hopefully is
replicable where you can have not only
organizational interchange locally but
where you can
have the experience being made possible
internationally on the basis of what it
is you learn and a exchange of views on
what the donor countries are
learning and then you have another issue
the donor countries
learn many of them but not all are
democratic but they also subject to
their own
challenges in the last three years as I
need hardly tell you the situation in
Europe starting with Greece Portugal
Spain the situation in the European
market the situation in the economy in
our country have all changed
dramatically since many of the plans
were made for
development and so what we've seen is
both a visible reduction of finance and
support and also a lot of kidding about
what it is that is going on they don't
want to announce that they've cut an aid
program by x% but the truth is it's
going on all around the world and delays
are being made and the work is not being
done and so the issue of continuity the
issue of focus which is so important in
business is really not there
from the rich countries to the less rich
countries until 2002 it was easy to
think of it you had 80% of the world uh
was in the developing
countries uh no I'm sorry 80% of the of
the uh income of the world was in the
rich
countries
20% was in the poor countries so you had
a billion people with 80% of the income
and you had 5 billion people with 20% of
the income and for more than 30 years
plus or minus 1 or 2% that was the
situation and so we and the rich
countries used to argue with each other
as whether you'd give another 0.1 or0 2%
you may remember that there was a Target
set of 7/10 of 1% of the income of rich
countries to go to development it never
made it in most
countries and even that that
was uh unstable in the sense that we
didn't achieve the
objective what is happening now are
really two things the first thing that's
happening which you should
recognize is that the income streams are
changing that
8020 is now
6535 in other words the developing
countries have 35% of the global
income and they dramatic changes taking
place in terms of who is going to be
running the world in terms of economic
activity and indeed probably in terms
also of political
activity the expectation is that by
2050 unlike the ad20 that made us all
comfortable in having a G7 and feeling
that the Europeans plus Japan had all
the money we're now finding that there
is a big change
occurring and the expectations are that
by
2050 that 80% which we had for so many
years will be down to
35% and the developing countries which
used to have the 20% will be up to
65% and of that
65% 50% of it will be in the hands of
China and India
50% that is a world that is very
different than the world we're talking
about today it's a world of 9 and a half
million people at that time in which 50%
of the global income will be in two
countries and close to 60% in
Asia this is a remarkable
change which is manifested in very many
ways and really not understood by my
generation at
all the truth of the matter is that
there are 350,000 Chinese students
studying a year abroad 330 ,000 Indian
students studying
abroad 130,000 Chinese studying in this
country I think 120,000 Indians studying
here in response we have 13,000 students
studying in China and 3,100 in
India and if I talk about this at
universities or in front of both
students and their parents they all say
that's terrible I'm going to send my
daughter or son to China or I'm going to
do something else and and the next day
they've forgotten
it but the truth of the matter is that
that is not just a statistical
challenge that is a change in our world
that is a change that is happening at a
very very rapid rate and where the
Dynamics are that we're having a shift
uh to Asia which none of us has seen
before and was last seen in
1815 when China and India were 50% of
the global GDP and before that in
1500 so it's happened before and it's
happening again and we're holy
unprepared generally for it as you look
forward to see what's going to happen by
2050 the GDP of China will be 70 billion
trillion the US 38 trillion India 38
trillion then Brazil 11 trillion Mexico
9 Russia 8 indes IA
seven Japan nearly seven UK five Germany
five the fascinating thing about that is
that only three of the G7 are then in
the top 10 and they're replaced by many
other countries which include India
Mexico Brazil which in my day were the
sort of countries that we were trying to
help this is the drama of the change
that is going on
and is a dramatic change and a great
challenge to all of us here and indeed
to the world that is
coming but there is one area of the
world which to our to our hosts is
critically important which is what about
the billion people that are living in
absolute
poverty under a125 a day the substantial
majority of them are in Africa not all
but a substantial majority at least 70%
% in 53
countries and it is a very very
difficult area in which to bring about
change first of all you have the massive
issue of corruption which I'm afraid
still is endemic in so many parts of the
country the second thing is that you
don't have a core a significant core of
educated people that are prepared to
give themselves to public
service if you're educated and you're
from a good family go into business or
you try and you very rarely go to
government in the past fortunately what
we're seeing is that there is now a
change
occurring that many young Africans are
starting to think that they can be
responsible they can still make an
adequate amount of money and they can
still bring about a change in that
continent but Africa remains at the
epicenter of the issues that we're going
to try and
confront and it is very very difficult
to talk to Young Africans about
entrepreneurship about the issues that
our Founders are concerned with
managerial issues and
Technology when all too many of them
can't read have not had the education
system and are just not prepared to take
the
responsibilities so we have a huge
challenge for educational institutions
like Stanford and by initiatives that
are taken by development institutions to
get out and bring about the human
capital that is essential in these
countries you can't do it all at once
and the last thing I'll say is that the
whole of this challenge uh which has
been put To Us by the Kings is not an
instant
solution it is something that will take
decades and continuous effort and that's
why housing at here in Stanford is a
wonderful thing and gives us an opport
Community I hope to think about Hope and
to think about a better world that all
of you are going to create than the
world that I had some part in thank you
very
[Applause]
much
minutes yeah
you those excuse me those numbers you
were quoting as to the size of the
various economies
what uh what lies behind them in terms
of income distribution do we expect
the sorry the the numbers you were
quoting on the size of various economies
including some that are
still filled with hundreds of millions
of poor people uh when you see China
being a $70 trillion economy what does
that assume about the income
distribution in China are there still
going to be poor people in China with
those kinds of numbers well until
2001 it was and even until
2011 it was clear that the middle class
was 2/3 in the rich countries as I
described and one3 in the rest of the
world that was on a purchasing power
parity basis that wasn't even dollar for
dollar that that was allowing for the
change in the value of the dollar it's
thought that within 10 Years it'll be
the reverse 2/3 particularly in Asia and
onethird in the so-called rich countries
estimates vary whether it's 10 years or
15 years but it's in that time frame
that that will
change and this is reflected in the GDP
statistics that was giving you if you're
going to see the statistics move from
20% of the world's income to those 5
billion people or are now 6 billion and
you say going to see that now going to
35 and then ultimately to
65 you have to have a greater push now
it would be possible for it to go to a
few ruling families but that is not the
case typically in China and India there
are some some very rich families in both
places but the weight of the population
is is such and the weight of the
actually the politics is such that it's
my belief that you're going to see a
much broader base of a distribution two
places will be challenging the current
one is in the Arab
world and if you take Saudi Arabia you
probably got half the income in the
hands of 5 7,000 members of the Royal
Family
that by the way is an inherent danger in
that country in terms of political
stability and the other place where it
is at the moment hugely uneven is
Africa by the way also in some parts of
Latin America but improving in Latin
America but in
Africa U governance is not a great
thing and when you get into Power it's
hard to get you
out and
corruption is
unfortunately very high I should tell
you that when I got to the World Bank
nickel remember this the first time in
1995 in my second speech at an annual
meeting
I sent the draft to the general counsel
and I had a phrase in I was dealing with
the cancer of
corruption and he came to my office and
he said will you come outside I said why
can't you talk to me here he said no I'd
like to talk to you outside and we went
out into the atrium and he whispered to
me he said Jim you cannot use the
CW and I said what the hell is the CW he
said corruption I said why can't I use
the CW he said half the members of your
board represent corrupt
countries and I tell you this because 6
months later every every delegate talked
about corruption with the other people
not with their own country but the issue
of corruption is still fundamental
unfortunately and
um I regret to say that is one of the
bigger challenges that we have to
face yes sir I wanted to ask about your
thoughts on prospects for Africa so I
understanding as Africa is roughly at
the same income Capal level it may have
been 20 30 40 years ago what extent you
see things improving going forwards
particular I wondered whether as the
world gets richer put loose
multinationals for example looking for
locost production cers
move um I you know my sense is the world
seems more optimistic in Africa looking
ahead recently you have much more yeah
it's slightly more U it's slightly more
but the average per capita income is
still under $1,000 a year and the most
extreme projections I've seen for 2050
is an average po an average per capita
income of $5,000 per year that's at a
time when India will be 25,000 and China
will be
40,000 and we'll be 880,000 or 100,000
in the richest countries so you have to
think about a world in which you have
two billion people in Africa more than
20% no longer running around with Spears
and with no means of
communications but with cellular radios
and with the means of moving around 2
billion uh that are dissatisfied in
terms of the of their share of what
they're getting so they can move with
their feet which they do into Europe and
in other
places and there are all sorts of things
that they can do if they're
unhappy center of the drug trade in many
areas is now shifted to
Africa uh there are many good things
happening in Africa I'm not I must say
that categorically in terms of both
education in terms of in terms of um new
ideas and some very good leaders I'm I'm
deeply impressed by the changes in
Africa in the last 15 years but if
you're if your object if your assumption
is that the size of the population is
going to double in the next 30 30 to 40
years and if you still have a decent
increase in annual income the per capita
income is held back by the population
growth and that's what's happening now
the interesting thing is that it will
have the youngest population in the
world while we're getting older so the
question is what is going to happen in
these centers of increased population
growth and what is it that Africa can do
in terms of training the young people
and that I think is something that is a
challenge for educational institutions
but for the governments in those
countries and I think give some hope to
Africa you
say you say a little bit more about
corruption in the following sense that
many of the countries that you are
discussing have corruption is an not an
essential the essential part of the
political system right the people in
power couldn't govern without corruption
so we not going to be able to get rid of
it entirely somehow the problem has to
be addressed but how do you think about
dealing with that issue well you have to
do it in two ways uh in Singapore if you
want to get a country company registered
you have to go to two people and you get
it
registered in many of the other
countries you have to go to 30 or 40
people and if you go to 30 or 40 people
to get your company registered or to get
a driver's license or to get whatever it
is that you want uh each one of those
steps costs a few dollars
and the reason that that cost a few
dollars is it has become accepted part
of the system that it's part of the
salary
scale and you buy your job depending on
the income that you can expect from that
job and that is can only be dealt with
by a clean government coming in and
trying to establish first of all a
profit tax system so that they got the
income and secondly a more rational
payment me mechanism for public
officials if you can do that then you
won't have 35 steps to get your approval
you'll have five steps or three steps or
four steps the interesting thing is that
you can measure the level of corruption
in a curious way by the number of steps
you need to have to get approvals on
various things and so this is starting
to happen in some
countries
and you as I said before to the the
Kings it's not going to happen overnight
but what is important is that you start
the initiative so that you can make sure
that as you press it down the road it
will get done it didn't get done by the
way in England or the United States in 5
minutes
either uh you need to remember that it
was not always uh so perfectly honest uh
as it is thought to be in some places
today and by the way corruption is not
totally left even our country uh the
numbers just get bigger uh but um I
think that the direction is set and what
is interesting now is
that in developing countries a lot of
interesting things are
happening first of
all there's a woman called enoia wo who
worked at the bank who's now the Finance
Minister of Nigeria she was a close
colleague of mine she puts on the doors
of all the schools in the educational
program the amount of money that has
been sent from head office to that
school you think that would be not a
particularly genius thing to do it has
indeed transformed the amount of money
that gets in the educational system to
schools she just decided that she would
let each Community know what they were
being sent and when 30% of it was
arriving on what they' sent from
Lagos things start to change and it's
the community that does it it's not a
policeman it's the community and so
there are many ways in which
transparency can have a big effect and
personally I think that this is the way
that in many countries it's going to go
it's the same thing is true in transfer
of money and
resources once we have the
telephone to move money around there's
less chance of being robbed as you try
and use the financial system and that's
already happening that's why people are
using the phone so there technology I
think can make a big difference
particularly if it brings about
transparency and it's my hope that as
that moves forward we'll see some
significant
improvements i' got a question here um
at the moment
a small set of countries are sort of the
deliverers of resources for initiatives
of this do you think that in I say 10
two or three decades away that we'll see
China and India and those countries
playing that sort of role as well as um
something that may be more uh
financially
driven you mean helping developing
countries yes well that's already
happening um they make more noise about
it at the moment than substance to be
quite honest and they'll announce a 10
billion
program and it will more or less get
through but 10 billion in the
international scene is still only a tip
relative to what is needed for the
development in these countries but
they're much better than we are in terms
of following up I mean the premier and
the vice Prem and the Prime Minister of
China go to Africa never less than once
orce a year each
one they don't have immediate um
Financial return but they're
establishing themselves and there are
now a million Chinese living in
Africa and the issue there is natural
resources so they're staking a
claim uh where our
president and the leaders of many other
countries have maybe never been to
Africa or if they've been there once it
was for two
days so the
identification of these opportunities
and the following up on them by the
Asians including the Indians who by the
way have a big resident community in
East Africa as
well they've got a good start on the
African development they understand it
they got people that live
there uh there's some friction with the
Chinese because they're not they're not
really um settling in as members of the
community they have their separate
communities essentially when they're
there
but you would have to say that the move
towards natural
resources and the linkage with China and
India particularly China is
fundamental and it's what's driving it
it's not I think good heart although
there are many Chinese with very good
Hearts it is that is a matter of public
policy for the natural resources that
are going to be demanded and are being
demanded by the giant population in
China Africa becomes very important oil
will and
mine and by the way now also uh a place
to grow food where there you know there
are many initiatives going on to to do
food production in
Africa I think I've just about done my
time haven't I
thank h